I've been driving along Australia's
famous great ocean road and I'm stopped
here near the 12 apostles which are
these big sandstone Bluffs actually
there's only eight of them left because
the others have eroded over time and
erosion is really what's given us this
coastline the way it looks now so that
brings to mind a question for me which
is how long is the Australian coastline
well if you were to measure it out in
lengths of five hundred kilometres you
would find that it's about twelve and a
half thousand kilometers long but the
CIA world factbook puts the figure at
more than double that over twenty five
thousand seven hundred kilometers but
how can it be that we have two different
estimates for the length of the same
coastline well this is called the
coastline paradox the answer is it
depends on the length of measuring stick
that you use so if you connect up the
dots from cliff to cliff to cliff you
get a shorter length of coastline than
if you measure with a smaller measuring
stick and measure into every inland so
what length the measuring stick should
we use well in theory you can go all the
way down to the size of a water molecule
and if you do that then the length of
Australia's coast is virtually infinite
do you believe me that you could have a
finite area object like Australia
bounded by an infinite perimeter it
doesn't seem to make sense
but I can give you another example of
this it's called the Koch snowflake so
what you do is you take a triangle with
sides of length one and then on each
side add another triangle with sides of
length the third continue doing that
again and again forever and what you end
up with is a shape which is a finite
area but an infinite perimeter shapes
like these are called fractals and many
coastlines have this same fractal
structure which means they have some
sort of self-similarity
on many different scales so you can zoom
in and zoom in and the coastline looks
roughly the same so if you want to know
the length of a coastline you need to
first specify the length of your
measuring stick because that's what the
answer depends on
wife